couple weeks ahead
ladies and gentlemen sing it if you know
the words this is Hans Kim this is
[Music]
hell yeah
it's gonna be here happy Asian American
and Pacific Islander Heritage Month
[Music]
I know this month my entire career
[Laughter]
I mean the career of my dreams
at this rate the entire Asian population
will be on a side in two billion years
but uh yeah good to be here
um
I uh yes the uh the whole economy is
doing great I think that's amazing
um
I think that it's sad that all the kids
nowadays care about is transphobia
back in my day we could entertain
ourselves for hours with just a little
bit of homophobia
I like how all these Millennials are
trying to call Trump a sex offender
it's like yeah he did it but that wasn't
his main thing
it's like calling Michael Jordan a
baseball player
thank you
hell yeah brought it together there at
the end look at you you sneaky devil
thank you you uh you uh you're good at
like filling time when you can't think
of your jokes for a second there was a
moment there about 20 seconds in where
you took a moment to tell us all that
the economy is doing great
you sneaky little devil Hans what's
going on when in your head when you're
saying things like that when you say
well it's good to be here after you've
already done some jokes normally people
say it's good to be here before
are you like forgetting are you trying
to think yeah I'm just like you only
have a minute to do How Could You Forget
a joke already you idiot right right
that's what I was thinking too I'm
kidding Han's my sweet boy you just
reminded me indeed that this is the
first day of Asian Heritage Month this
is a big big month for me
it really is thank you Tony can we ask
him what it actually means yes what does
Asian Heritage Month meet
it means everyone's watching right now
do you know what it means yeah it means
respect and honor
it's like we're in a kung fu movie yeah
it's kind of like Rosh Hashanah for Jews
what's up yeah it's like it's rice
Hashanah
that should have gotten a bigger laugh
checking on you guys rice Hashanah oh
they don't know Jewish they don't even
know what Rosh Hashanah is these Texas
people are like what's a Jew
laughs what the hell
Hans uh what is your relationship uh
with Jews I love them I you know we're
we're very similar we're very
mathematically minded yeah uh we both
aren't very sexually uh powerful oh I
didn't know that was a Jewish stereotype
sexually powerful I've always no one's
like oh go get [__] by the Jew he'll
[__] your brains out right normally when
you get [__] by a Jew it's at the bank
or something oh there you are no rice
Hashanah but you know the bat okay
[__] yeah
I love it Hans you uh did sold out shows
this weekend and where's San Diego San
Diego oh lovely you're out there killing
it dude thank you Tony all thanks to you
and Joe and everybody here and oh no no
no no no it was me okay it was me this
[__] these people these people are
from Portland what the [__] did they
ever do for you
so Hans you walked by all those the the
kids outside in the in the alley correct
yeah I pulled my moped back there it
used to be one of those kids so what's
it like walking over those kids now yeah
when I'm walking over them I'm uh just
thinking wow I can't believe I was one
of them like I was I like this I don't
think so
whatever
there's Tony's influence right there
you're goddamn right
all my people are built with a strong
confident backbone
Hans what else anything crazy happen I
took my girlfriend with me to San Diego
oh thank you yeah how did that go for
you uh it went not that well yeah tell
us about it she slept a lot she only saw
one of my shows yeah and then she got
mad at me
and then I don't know why it's either
because I was playing Catan or because I
was
well you're also like an Austin six and
a half thank you Derek but like in San
Diego
yeah she probably got a taste of a real
Asian man out there huh oh whoa fresh
off a naval base or something yeah she
wasn't sleeping yeah
all right Hans wow all right we love you
I love it we do we love you you're so
great at getting the show started
congratulations on another fun set we'll
see you again next week huh thank you
Tony buddy
[Music]
those jokes were fast as Lightning what
Tony